what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so with the trailer for thor
ragnarok i guess the second trailer for
thor ragnarok having dropped at the tail
end we got our first view of Surtur and
i got to be honest i didn't think we
would see him like i honestly did not
believe we would see Surtur and thor
ragnarok he looks amazing but i didn't
think we would see him those of us who
were new to Marvel Comics
Serdar is basically the king of the fire
demons and he is the arch-nemesis he's
like the main enemy of Odin but he's
also an enemy of Thor he's really more
like an archenemy of Odin more so than
Thor Thor's main enemy is of course
low-key but Surtur's more powerful than
both of them and it's really kind of
funny because when it comes to the
Asgardian gods there is a hierarchy from
the oldest being the most powerful to
the newest being the least powerful
because remember Odin is not the first
king of Asgard
he's something like the third or fourth
king of Asgard it's a family lineage and
it goes all the way back to borea I
think it was and then bori had Bor and
embed Cole and Odin and V Lee and V and
then like Odin ended up having Thor it
was something along those lines but
there's like different you know
hierarchies to it but the fact remains
the older ruler is the more powerful
they were just because of the fact that
they were dealing with you know far
stronger enemies back then this were
just a way for Marvel to kind of tone
down how powerful people become over the
years for example when Thor has his own
offspring they'll be weaker than Thor is
it's just one of those ways that Marvel
kind of deals with those those
interesting scenarios but as far as
Serdar himself his origin is intertwined
into the origin of Asgard and that's
kind of a benefit but it's also a
downside with regards to the formation
of Asgard again all really told us that
it was just fair one day like there were
just realms that were there there were
basically land masses they kind of you
know coalesced converse and eventually
gave birth to Asgard and then even then
you know among the various gods that
emerge there's kind of like origin
stories on damn again that's all covered
as part of tales and how the tales of
Asgard and for the most part we might
actually go through I start talking
about those because there's some pretty
cool information in those those
particular stories but as far as sort of
goes there's really not an explanation
in terms of like when he was born or
anything along those lines because it
doesn't need to be modeled never really
gave us any of that stuff when it came
to those characters instead what they
did is they provided us kind of equal
footing among all these different beings
and so Surtur is to the fire demons what
luffy is to the frost giants if you saw
the first Thor movie and it dealt with
the idea of the frost giants went for
kind of
on his own alongside Loki and then Odin
had to basically show up and bail him
out and then banned him from from Asgard
lafi was essentially the king of the
frost giant he was the most powerful of
the frost giants in the realm of Marvel
Comics Cerner is the most powerful of
all the fire demons and so again it's
just these different realms where
different beings exist now the reason
why it is that Surtur is so prominent in
Marvel Comics and the reason why he's so
significant really more so than like in
a lafi of the frost giants or anything
actually came in journey into mystery
issue number 99 again during the tales
of Asgard backup feature for this story
and what it did is it basically gave us
a set of events whereby Odin ended up
travelling to face off against the
against the trolls on his way to face
off against the fire demon Surtur now
the reason why this was so significant
is because Odin himself has what's
called the odinforce and the odinforce
truth be told is really just Marvel
giving Odin a power that Lenin lets him
do pretty much whatever he needs to do
at any particular point in time it's a
plot device and the reason why we know
that is because mod will never specifies
here's what the odinforce can do and
here's what the odinforce cannot do it's
not like the odinforce gives Odin super
strength and speed and durability and
like a healing factor and that's it it's
allowed him to do any number of things
he's been able to face off against
Celestials he's been able to go
toe-to-toe against Galactus he's been
able to do all different kinds of things
as just a power Marvel gives him to
inject him into a story to make it
important now the caveat to this is that
it's like a battery if Odin uses 50% of
the odinforce Finny has to sleep however
long you need to in order to recharge
that 50% the more of the odinforce he
uses the longer he sleeps it's called
the Odin sleep that's why he ends up
here more or less crashing out it's like
coming down off a carb-load or something
like that but the fact remains here that
the odinforce is basically a power
that's given to Odin that is effectively
the life essence of its two brothers
villian V and so the reason why this
ended up happening is because of the
fact that in the early days when they
were younger
Odin Vili and V when to go fight Surtur
V and V were effectively killed and then
they bonded Odin with their life force
which in turn allowed him to basically
go back and face off against Surtur and
so this really kind of brings up that
conflict and essentially has Odin
inserter fighting off against each other
now keep in mind
Surtur it's wildly powerful and again
he's more powerful than Odin is I mean
it's insane the amount of
Howard he possesses he's the most
powerful in his home dimension but it's
also Odin basically being able to at the
very least capitalize on a momentary
weakness and a momentary bit of humors
and so what is up happening here is
because Serdar is struggling to face off
against Odin in this particular scenario
he actually ends up retreating and
travelling over to earth now again the
idea here is that earth serves as
Midgard so to speak and so when it comes
to Asgard and the nine realms the best
way to think about this is a Hall of
doors
if the Hall represents like Idris oh you
know the The Tree of Life or whatever
you want to call it then the doors
represent the different realms and you
can walk from one realm to the other the
difference here is you can't just like
go there you can't drive to Asgard you
can't drive to Jotunheim you can't drive
to Muspelheim or anything like that you
have to teleport there basically by way
of the Bifrost or the Rainbow Bridge
from Asgard there's other ways to get
there like Doctor Strange can get there
by opening portals anybody who can
teleport from one place to another who
can travel through dimensional flames
can get to you know these different
realms most of the most of the time they
don't because they're realms that are
basically confined like four storeys I
mean Doctor Strange has done it before
but it's not something that you see very
often it's usually just Thor who goes
through these different locations but
the fact remains that was Sir travelling
to earth Odin who's basically empowered
at this point kind of running on 100% of
the odinforce is basically able to trap
Surtur within the realm of Earth but
remember because of the fact that
sorters so powerful he can't be killed
per se he can't necessarily be destroyed
by Odin it doesn't work that way instead
Surtur is kind of like this immutable
representation of destruction in the
realm of Asgard and so the result is
that where Odin is able to lock him away
temporarily I believe that Surtur
escapes maybe once although I don't
think he does I want to say he joins
Loki for time British basically confined
and held prisoner until it leads to the
final conflict between himself and Odin
now in terms of this a little bit of an
origin the question becomes what role is
he going to play in Thor Ragnarok I
don't have the answer to that question
the Thor Ragnarok movie seems to be
starkly different from the Thor Ragnarok
story because the Thor Ragnarok story
basically dealt with the idea or the
death of Thor I mean model was getting
ready to write civil war and they
couldn't have four in that story
otherwise you were just tilted the odds
in the in favor of whatever team he was
facing off against the same reason why
they remove
The Incredible Hulk Civil War never
would have lasted as long as it did if
like The Incredible Hulk and Thor were
both in those conflicts there's a
what-if story where Thor actually shows
up during World War Hulk but civil war
never would have lasted that long so
they basically wrote them out instead
Ragnarok was this event that Marvel have
been teasing for like decades for years
and years and years and years and years
and finally it came to fruition with
Loki basically banning alongside Serdar
following the death of Odin and then
giving cert or hammer and giving you all
the different forces different weapons
that were form for metal the same metal
that Thor's Hammer's forged from and in
turn leading an invasion of Asgard
defeating four and the four years three
and all the ass guardians and then Thor
basically being cast out I mean Thor was
able to gain the aid of Captain America
and Iron Man in order to take back
Asgard and in Thor Ragnarok in the movie
it looks like The Incredible Hulk will
be a stand-in for Iron Man and Captain
America but for Ragnarok looks more like
Planet Hulk as opposed to the Ragnarok
story and sort of never played a role in
Planet Hulk so I have no idea what role
sorters going to play I have absolutely
no clue what's going to happen there at
the very least it seems like he may be
the person that ends up killing off Odin
we know Odin's out of the picture we
know he's been confined to earth or at
least that seems to be the case given
that one image that people were looking
at online as well as the post-credits
scene for Doctor Strange I think it was
but we don't know like I mean we have we
have a post-credits scene that scant is
best and that we have a singular image
like a singular set shot so if we have
no idea what's going on with Odin it
used to be the case you know most
everybody's kind of going with that
they're kind of assuming that is true um
but again it's kind of an interesting
scenario because I imagine cert or being
as powerful as he is look incredible
hulk facing off against him uh in Marvel
Comics The Incredible Hulk that posed no
threat disorder I mean incredible hoax
strong but Sir to has all different
kinds of magics and sorcery and like the
eternal blade at his side the internal
blade is absolutely crazy but he has all
these different weapons at his side he
could easily use to destroy the
Incredible Hulk so I have no idea why
the hopes there but I have no idea you
know how he's going to tie into it all
but it does look cool it does look like
it's going to be pretty solid and it
does look like it's going to be pretty
amazing so anyway guys again a quick
little ward on sorter not a whole lot to
work with really it's more of why it is
asserted is a mortal enemy of Odin just
because of the fact of the through it
and based off
like a four cage backup feature and Odin
basically locked him in earth and
because you know because he basically
suffered a humiliating defeat at the
hands of Odin he considered Odin to be
his his mortal foe remember because he
was walked away Surtur couldn't just
walk out he couldn't just escape he was
basically confined in the center of the
earth and eventually made his escape and
you know face off against Odin
eventually killed him but if you guys
are new here to comment to explain make
sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the robb course if you
guys enjoyed this video make sure you
drop a like and I will catch you all
later peace
[Music]